everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem task scheduler one of
you suggested this problem and i think
it's a pretty good one so we're given an
array of tasks it's a character array
and it's going to be limited to the
characters from uppercase a to uppercase
z so 26 characters each of the
characters represents a task and the
task is something that the cpu needs to
process and the tasks could be processed
in any order each task takes exactly one
unit of time to process so that's good
because it makes things simple for us
and for each unit of time the cpu could
either process an entire task or it
could be idle and the reason it would be
idle is because we're also given
non-negative integer input n that
represents the cooldown period between
the two same tasks and the same task is
represented by the same letter the same
character in the array and to understand
this let's take a look at an example and
by the way what we actually want to
return is the minimum number of units of
time that the cpu will take to finish
all of the tasks let's take a look at
this example we're given these tasks
right three a tasks and three b tasks
and the idle time we're given is two
units of time so basically let's say we
processed an a task right that takes us
one unit of time to process now we
process a b task and now we know that
before we process another a task we have
to wait two units of time so you know
let's say we process an a we can't
process another a we have to wait two
units of time before we can process
another a so what are we gonna do in the
meantime well there's a b as well so
let's process one of the b's and now for
this b we know we actually have to wait
two units of time before we can process
another b
so the next time we can process another
b will be at this point in time after we
have processed our second a so now the
question is can we fill this spot with
anything or are we gonna have to be idle
at this point in time and there aren't
any other characters right we had one a
and one b now we have two a's and two
b's remaining so we can't do anything
this has to be idle we process an a a
second a and a second b uh that means
that before we can process another a is
gonna be two units of time so this b and
then another uh unit of time and then
another a and we also process the b the
next time we can process a b will be at
this point in time so at this point
again we are going to have to be idle
but the good thing is that this is the
entire um like all the tasks we were
looking for three a's and three b's so
as you can see it took us one two three
four five six seven eight units of time
to do this so our output is going to be
a so now let's think about a general
approach that we could come up with to
solve this problem so let's say we had
this as our input first thing to notice
is we're going to be given characters a
through z doesn't really make sense to
worry about which character we're
looking at right there's not really not
a big difference between a b and a c but
we should keep track of how many of each
character there is so we know there's
three a's two b's and two c's right we
don't even have to worry about the
characters anymore we can just focus on
the numbers we know that there's three
of one character there's two of a
different character and then two of
another character we know that the idol
time in this case is one what order
should we uh process the characters in
it's probably better to process the more
frequent character first the more
frequent task first because we know
there's going to be some idle time and
processing the more frequent one first
basically gives us more time to not be
idle and i'll show you the intuition
behind that let's say we did a c first
right we do c uh we know that idle time
is just one right so then let's say we
do b and we're allowed to do another c
right away let's say we do that right we
do another c and uh then we do another b
because we the idle times only one right
so now we've already processed all the
the c's and the b's and all we're left
with is three a's okay let's process one
of the a's okay great but now we have an
idle time we have no other characters
available for us so we have to wait
and then we can process another a and
then we wait and then process another a
so in this case this was one way but did
this minimize the total time that it
took us to process all the tasks a
different way would have been to start
with the most frequent character right a
and now there's only two a's left so now
what's the most frequent well you could
say a again but we know that there is an
idle time of at least one so at this
point in time a is not available to us
so we have to process a different
character let's say a b then a is
actually going to be available for us
again so we could process the a or we
could process the c in this case it
doesn't really make any difference
because there's two of each of these so
we could do either one let's just do c
so then there will be two a's one b and
one c then we'll of course want to do
the more frequent character the a and
then there's gonna be one a remaining we
can't process another a without at least
one unit of idle time so let's do b and
then do c and then we can do a right
this
also is a valid way and this one
actually minimizes the idle time rather
than
this one and what is the idle time in
this case it's about uh not the idle
time the total time in this case is
about seven as opposed to nine in the
other case so that's kind of the
intuition why we're going to
try to do the more frequent task first
and then the less frequent task how
we're going to be doing this is by using
a data structure called a max heap which
will allow us to continuously figure out
which task is the most frequent one and
the max heap can actually allow us to
determine that in log n time right if we
have a bunch of these we could figure
out which is the most frequent in log in
time which is good but in this case
actually it's even better than that it's
about log 26 since we only have 26
different characters this is kind of a
constant time operation anyway but i
will say that the overall time
complexity is still going to be big o of
n one because we are gonna have to you
know count the occurrences of each task
so we're gonna have to go through the
entire uh input and we're going to be
you know popping every value from our
max heap and adding every value to our
max heap so the time complexity is going
to be big o of n that's also going to be
the memory complexity but now to the
actual algorithm itself we're actually
going to use one other data structure aq
it's not required but i think it makes
the problem a little bit more organized
so let's start off with the max heap
right we have three integers we're going
to be adding integers to our max heap
not the characters we're going to be
taking the counts of each task and
adding that to the max heap so we're
going to have a three and a two and a
another two and by the way when i
actually code this up in python we don't
have a native max heap so the way to we
only have a min heap so the way i get
around that is basically by taking each
of these values and making it negative
you know in a max heap we want to pop
the maximum and we can do that in log n
time so in this case we'd pop the 3
which is the maximum but in python we're
actually going to do it the opposite way
all of these are going to be negative so
we're going to end up popping the
minimum which is going to be negative 3
but we're going to you know assume that
it's a positive 3. but yeah so that's
the idea first we're going to pop the 3
or the negative 3. you can think about
it however you want that's the most
frequent but now we want to change the
count from being a three to now being a
two right because we just processed one
of the tasks so you know if you have a
negative you'll have to add one if you
have a positive you can decrement it to
one in my case when i write the code i'm
going to be adding one to this but now
we're actually going to be taking this
and adding it to our queue data
structure because we know that there's
some amount of idle time for this task
at the current point in time we are at
initially we were at time equals zero
but we just processed the task so now
we're at time equals one and we're going
to add this integer 2 or negative 2 to
our q
but we're also going to be adding
another value to the queue and that's at
what time is this task going to be
available for us to process once again
basically at what point can we take this
and add it back to our max heap right
what's the idle time that is going to be
remaining well right now we're at time
equals one and our idle time for each
task is n equals one so basically we're
gonna take n
and add it to our current time so it's
gonna be two basically at time equals
two this task is gonna be available for
us to add to the heap again so that's
what the second value in this case means
and once again we're going to pop from
our max heap we're going to pop the
negative 2 and that means we have
processed the task so now our time is
actually going to be time equals 2.
we're going to take that task it was a
negative 2. we're going to add 1 to it
which is going to make it a negative 1.
so then we're going to take that
negative 1 and add it to our q
and at what time is that task going to
be available to add back to our max heap
well it's going to be 2 plus 1 because n
is 1 in our case so at time equals 3
this task can be added back to our max
heap but now that we're at time equals 2
we see that this task actually is
available now to add back to our heap so
let's pop it from our q and take the
negative 2 and add it back to our max
heap and at this point you're probably
starting to get the idea so i'll just
kind of fast forward through this we're
going to pop this again set our time now
equal to 3. we're going to take that
negative 2 add 1 to it so it'll be a
negative 1. we'll add that to our heap
at time equals 4 it's going to be
available for us to add back to the heap
this value can be popped from our queue
we can add a negative 1 here and then
start the cycle over so let's pop this
value over here uh add it to our q we're
running out of space so let's add a
little bit more space uh that negative
two will become a negative one the time
now will actually be four so the time
that this can be popped it's going to be
at time five we see it's time for so
this can now be popped so we add that
back to our uh heap negative one and now
it's time equals four so i'm really
going to fast forward through this it'll
take one more unit of time to process
this task but now this task as you can
see we're going to pop it it's a
negative 1 we're going to add 1 to it so
now it's going to be 0 right 0 once a
task becomes 0 we know that we don't
have to process it anymore right so when
it's 0 we're not going to add it to our
q because it doesn't have to be idle
it's never going to be added back to the
max heap once it's zero we're not going
to do anything with it so uh you know we
pop it from our max heap and there's
nothing left but we see that this value
over here and right now it's going to be
time equals five actually so time is
five this can be added back to our max
heap
let's add that negative one sorry if
it's getting a little bit messy but next
we're gonna pop this from our max heap
it's gonna become zero so we don't add
it to our queue now it's gonna be time
equals six after we process that task
and lastly we have one task remaining we
pop it we process it it becomes zero we
don't add it to the queue so now after
processing that task our time is seven
so we can return seven in this case and
that's pretty much the entire algorithm
so that's what i'm going to be following
even though popping and pushing to a max
heap is usually a login operation in
this case it's really going to be a log
26 operation so the overall time
complexity in this case is really just
big o of n because we have to just go
through every single task okay now let's
write the code okay so now let's code it
up and you can see i have a couple
comments just to kind of help simplify
things for us and i usually don't do
this but we want to count the
occurrences of each character in the
input it's a list of strings we could
just you know run through that loop
through that and add it to a hash map
but you can actually do that with a
built-in way in python just using a
counter which is literally a hash map
it'll just do that for us so we don't
have to write the code but now we
actually want to create our max heap
using those counts themselves uh we can
do that in python with one line of code
we're just going to iterate through each
count in
the
hashmap that we just created but we want
to only iterate through the values so
count.values and we want to add that to
our hashmap but in python's case we
can't have a max heap this is actually a
min heap after we heapify it so i'm
actually going to take the negative of
the count and add it so this is just
creating an array with every negative
count that we computed but to actually
turn it into a heap
we can do
heapq.heapify in python and to that max
heap and it'll basically order it it'll
take this array and order it in such a
way that it is a max heap basically for
us to efficiently get the maximum value
from
the heap whenever we want it we're also
going to declare a variable to keep
track of what time it is initially we'll
set that to zero and we'll also have a q
in this case a double ended queue and
the double ended queue is gonna actually
contain a pair of values and the pair of
values are gonna be that negative count
that we had up above and for that uh you
know task that count
the corresponding idle time at what time
is it going to be available for us to
add back to the
max heap okay so with that said we're
gonna continue uh our loop we're gonna
continue processing these tasks while
the max heap is non-empty but end or not
and but or the
cue is not empty right as long as one of
these is not empty that means we have
more tasks that we need to process
so as we process
each iteration of the loop is just going
to increment the time by exactly one and
actually before i even forget i
mentioned that the time complexity of
this whole algorithm is going to be big
o of n but that's not entirely correct
let's say n is the size of our tasks we
can add one more variable let's call it
m where m actually represents what the
idle time is because in the worst case
you know we have to go through that idle
time for each task that we have write
suppose that the tasks was just an array
of all a's
in that case we'd have to you know go
through the idle time for each task but
the idle time is actually a pretty small
constant i think it's less than 100 in
our case but just wanted to mention that
in case but okay now let's continue with
the algorithm so at each iteration of
loop we're going to increment the time
by one if the max heap is non-empty we
are going to pop from it and we can do
that with heap q dot heap pop from the
max heap and from it we're gonna get the
count and as we uh pop from the heap
that means we're processing this task so
to the count itself we can actually add
one to it because remember we're
actually using negative values for the
counts if you were using positive values
you'd probably subtract one from it but
in our case we're going to be adding one
to it and if this count is non-zero we
can check that uh like this if count is
non-zero then we want to go ahead and
append it to our queue and we can do
that like this we're gonna append a pair
of values the count itself and the time
that it's going to be available again
and we can get that by taking our time
our current time adding to it the idle
time n so at this time we can once again
add it to our maxi okay that's great we
process a task we remove it from the max
heap but remember we also have to take
care of our queue if our queue is
non-empty and the first value in our
queue at index 0
the idle time for it which is also
it was actually going to be at index one
because it's the second value in the
pair so if this time has just been
reached so if this is equal to the
current time that means you know we can
actually pop this from our queue so
we're going to say q dot popped left and
so this is actually going to pop that
pair of values and from that pair of
values we care about the first one which
is the count so we're going to get an
index of zero but actually that value
itself what do we want to do we just
want to add it back to our max heap so
we can do that with heap cue.heat push
we're going to take it add it to our max
heap so let's just copy and paste this
and uh move it up above so the only
thing left for us to do is once
everything has been processed for our
max heap and our queue we can just go
ahead and return the time that it took
us to do all that work let's just clean
this up a little bit that's the entire
code so now let's just run it to make
sure that it actually works and as you
can see on the left yes it does work and
it's pretty efficient i do want to
mention there actually is a different
solution for this that's actually a
little bit more of a true linear time
solution but i think it's a lot less
intuitive and i think this solution is
perfectly fine for interviews and
because it's more of an intuitive
solution i think this is
more or less what interviewers would
expect you to come up with so i really
hope that this was helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it really
supports the channel a lot consider
checking out my patreon where you can
further support the channel and
hopefully i'll see you pretty soon
thanks for watching